Small businesses are so on the rope right now.
And I wanted to ask you about this a little bit, because you know, in,
in some of the reading and writing that I've been doing,
like we found that there's been just a massive transfer of, of revenue,
of commerce, of wealth. You know,
you have some of these companies like Amazon, um,
and square and,
and Apple and all these huge behemoth companies to have.
All the $2 trillion company. Yeah.
And yet small businesses,
our data shows that small businesses are down on average,
about 20 plus percent and 30% have permanently closed at this
point. And that's growing. And what I worry about,
and I want to know what you think about this is how do we put that genie back in
the bottle? Because the trend just seems really hard right now.
You need to dramatically rebalance the economy.
If you're going to give small businesses a chance to reopen or open a new,
uh, so you would need something like universal basic income, honestly,
to have a shot because you have Apple breaking 2 trillion,
you have Amazon just sucking so many businesses dry.
Well.
And I think the other complicating factor that we all need to learn together is
how does that process of change actually happen?
Because I think we get this wrong.
I think that there's a certain segment of the population right now that thinks
like demonizing Joe Biden or Donald Trump will make that change
happen.
But we've had plenty of politicians do really things that were worthy
of demonization many times in the past, and that didn't really fix it.
And I think if anything,
we need to try to find a way to rise above those things and really talk to each
other. So, you know, for me being from rural Idaho,
a lot of the people that I grew up with are our Trump Maga people, um,
or they're libertarians or they're people that are kind of predisposed to not
necessarily, uh, want to join some of these solutions,
like what you're talking about.
And what I'm finding is when I actually just see them as a human being,
that's flawed the way I am.
That's learning the way I am and have a conversation.
And don't try to kind of like extricate them from my life because our beliefs
don't line up or the way we vote doesn't line up. And I just listened to them.
We actually can influence each other and come together. And I think, you know,
we need to be careful because right now the, the,
the predominant way of persuasion is kind of by like shaming and bullying each
other.
And I don't know if that's going to get people into the fold of something like
this. I'm pretty sure it's not Dan. And as you've shown for,
for a long time, and we're all seeing in real time, unfortunately right now,
like we need these changes. These changes are not really optional.
If we want to protect our way of life,
which means using a sub optimal form of connection, persuasion,
influence, whatever you want to call it.
I don't know that we can afford to do that right now.
And so I think a lot of people kind of on the liberal side of the equation,
you know,
need to soften up and engage a little bit more and not be so kind of like harsh
and mean sometimes.
Or maybe even find a way to frame some of the changes that we're
making. You know, it's one reason why, uh, we, Chris and universal basic income,
the freedom dividend is because it tested better with broader swaths of the
population.
Yeah. It was hard for me to switch back. I liked it that much,
and now we're kind of back to basic income. Uh,
and I actually loved the freedom dividend as a branding as a way of explaining
it.
Yeah, yeah, no, it is kind of funny. Um, but I,
I think that language really helped that make the case to different types of
people. There could be some of your old neighbors in rural Idaho, it'd be like,
I'm down with the freedom dividend. It's like it's, uh, uh, and,
and what, what you're describing as like the,
the barriers between us and trying to make the case of different types of
people, just like you have these market centers around how companies treat their
workers. Unfortunately, there are market centers around politics where, uh,
political figures get rewarded more for ginning up like a
passionate group of people, uh,
on a particular side than they do in reaching out and, uh,
solving problems. And that's going to destroy us, but,
but it's baked into, um,
the way a lot of candidates have to run where they're much more concerned about
getting primary primary by someone in their district,
because they're a safe seat, uh,
than they are in reaching to out to different types of people.
I mean, I, I've been trying to write and encourage people lately. Like, Hey,
like I get that there's a lot of horrible things happening,
but like putting some focus on the solutions,
putting some focus on the changes that we want to have happen is really our
best bet in this situation.
More so than the latest scandal that's going to keep us kind of all ginned up
for an extra week or two.
These folks who are trying to turn us against each other, like just ignore them.
Like the fact is we know how to solve our problems. Like you get it. I get,
it were pretty much like the same. We have the same motivations.
Like let's just come together and get this thing done. Well,
now 55% of Americans are for universal basic income.
And it's something like 76% are for cash relief during the pandemic,
which I have to say is going to be, uh,
a natural lead into universal basic income. Uh, so,
so Dan what's fascinating is I feel like you and I were kind of early on
this, but now many, many millions of Americans have joined us.
And now the big challenge is,
is how the heck do we restore the connection between people
and lawmakers, where if enough of us want something, it actually happens. Uh,
and, and so that's something I'm now engaged with very directly,
because I see that the mechanics of our democracy are actually going to be,
um, something we have to solve for,
and then also includes our media or social media. It's, it's interesting,
but I now think that that's going to be, um,
one of the foremost challenges to trying to have something like universal basic
income pass.
Can you give me a little bit of the playbook on that?
Cause that'll help me to be out there, you know, like walking the walk,
talking the talk with you.
Sure. Uh,
so the first big move would be something around democracy reform,
like rank choice voting. So if you have ranked choice voting,
then people will, uh, be able to vote, uh,
more dynamically. Uh, you know, they, they,
they wouldn't feel like they were going to like waste their vote. Uh,
and then you would make, let's call it, uh,
were they either Democrats or Republicans,
more responsive to different types of people in their district?
Because instead of just having to worry about like, someone probably beg them,
it could be that there are a couple of different points of view that they have
to account for.
And so if you're pro democracy then rank choice voting ought to be like
a and near absolute good. Uh, and so,
and it doesn't seem particularly partisan because it's not, it's like, look,
we should just try and improve our democracy. So it works better.
And it's more representative, uh,
and you can make very compelling arguments that people on on either side, um,
uh, that this would just be a better form of voting. Um,
so that's one big thing that I I'm going to be pushing and championing because
it's like a process change that strikes people as reasonable on both sides.
Yeah. Well, I'm, I'm right there with you. And I completely agree. I think also,
you know, getting money out of politics, it's just, we got to figure out a way,
I know what the Supreme court decision it's just really hard, but like,
we just have to do it because it's going to kill us.
That's exactly the kind of change that we need to make. So I was proposing as,
you know, a hundred democracy dollars for every, uh,
citizen so that you can just give it to your favorite candidate.
And then all of a sudden we could wash out the corporate money.
So that's a massive change that we need in the worst way.
Uh I'm for term limits for legislators,
because I just think it's too easy for someone to go to DC and then just make it
all about preserving their spot and like climbing this ladder.
And the ladder unfortunately stretches up for decades. So if you, Dan,
let's say you were to do something bold and run for Congress then and win.
And I would encourage this actually, uh,
till you have a business to run the rest of it. But, uh,
if you were to show up there, then they'd be like, all right,
now you're a low man on the totem pole go like dial for dollars.
And if you play your cards, right,
maybe you'll wind up on one of these awesome committees in like eight years or
something like that. Uh, and so the,
the that's not helping us solve these problems. Uh,
and so I think we should have term limits so that members of Congress see it as
a term of service and not like career,
then you go there and try and get something done and you turn around. Now,
there is a balancing act. Um, but to me, that that's necessary. Um,
because right now we have something of a,
gerontocracy where the average member of Congress,
I believe is about 62 years old, um,
which makes them a little bit behind the curve on technology issues among other
things. But, uh, but, uh, their,
their incentives aren't around solving our problems so much as they are staying
where they are. And,
and that is something that we need to address if we're going to make
progress. So, so these are some of the systemic fixes, um,
I'm going to be pushing for, um,
in the days to come and hopefully that message first it's needed,
but hopefully that message is so loud and powerful that we can
override, but you know, the, the software, you know, and, and, and in your case,
the, in my case, it was like, you know,
it's like the political software and the media software and the rest of it that
we have to try and override. Um, and they interest, you know,
in DC and the rest of it, uh,
in economy-wide though,
it it's true that corporations, the,
the logic of corporations will grind us to dust.
It will end up turning us into just like these,
these cogs in the machine and the machine will eventually discard us.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe.
The yang speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know,
every time we have a new episode.